yeah welcome to this video playing perch
para girl I don't know from Turkey let's
see Queens gambit the other triangle I
always like Quincy to him one reason
being that people keep playing a and 5
in this position just just a nice for
white check only check here yeah maybe
he's trying to know thought maybe he's
trying to play age 65 the scad enough
set up yeah this Bishop doesn't make so
much sense on on before really when the
night is on d 2 i'm also quick with the
controlling eform so he cannot play 94
here mm-hmm ah ok he's he's saying he
can play 94 yeah his right takes takes
Queen takes no I can hey I Queen takes
Bishop b2 of course yep was it g5 is a
hanging so I need to need to retreat
which is not a big problem but still I
didn't I didn't appreciate the smooth ok
so he wants to take and play again 94
I'm not sure yeah III is just preparing
to attack it not attacking it directly
yeah this will probably lead to somewhat
better and game for white rook the one I
guess okay one or group c 1 hard to tell
even we will take it now only 20 se for
us hanging get him yeah this is custom
just a very comfortable endgame from
white where my bishop is just far
stronger than his bishop um let's see
how to do that okay let's play G for
gain some space of the Kings side the
10g for intent g5 Bishop g5 that kind of
ideas it also isolates the porn on your
phone yeah yeah okay this is just very
bad it's giving me complete control over
the dark squares
let's see should I play f3 f3 takes look
everyone so one possibility I could also
just try to attack the pond but it said
this is a bit bit far-fetched this
maneuver okay let's just let's just do
that some simple solution I get the
spawn back anyway and the idea after
that is to to use the their foul
okay so before I am gaining space on the
queenside check wow I didn't expect that
ah ok on Bishop a6 he is planning Bishop
a six I didn't think about this move
because it's strategically so bad but
Bishop a6 many is the technical
justification yeah b5 you can take so I
probably must play c5 which isn't such a
problem because my bishop is stronger
than a rock but I didn't see it I just
didn't see that but really it's not a
big big problem this Bishop is such a
strong piece oreck beam was also not bad
but let's go here
look a six and c6 advancing the seep on
okc six you probably go to be too hmm
yeah i can go see six to enter with the
king yeah prolly should do that you
cannot even take h2o in the bishop on
your five is covering that the King d6
the plan okay let's go here
now let's see seven it's a bit much okay
King here f F F or 95 to stop the beer
pong and the dip on is not bad
yeah just d6 d7 don't see a defense
you like resigning yeah he's helpless
against that this was a bit lucky
because I overlooked this this idea
would be sure basics and it's just just
the position is so good that you can
even give away the exchange computer
points out 85 yeah okay yeah this is
good for black this is good for black
but this was the the the single chance
that he had after that it's it's already
excellent for white again yeah i played
this app latest 22 relaxed i mean i was
just thinking this was winning itself
but you need to be a bit a bit precise I
did it maybe instead of f3 I should just
just try to win the pawn this is may be
possible you can try something like that
and this is not so easy to prevent even
starting with c 5 which is also an idea
maybe this is more precise anyway
keeping this pawn here so that this
Bishop is never going to do anything
that's probably the more the more
precise way to play but this is this is
just keeping keeping a big advantage is
long yeah probably look everyone this is
also bad yeah yeah yeah i was playing
this a bit too too relaxed it's not a
bad move but it's not doing much and
mean the thing is I'm this kind of
formation completely freezes the King
side and I should try to focus on the
queenside to engineer breakthrough here
and they look f1 yeah ok it's ok but he
can play multi7 it does not it's not
really helping much and here i must play
something like that then in the long run
open up the Queen
yeah it was much better also a four is
not it's not a problem I mean it looks a
bit strange to not play this but he's
got those pods on dark squares and if
rooks I exchanged I will win the mall
and then even with the opposite
prohibitions it's a winning yeah I need
to play something like that this was
just bad jack and yeah I had overlooked
this but now here he needs to the IP
played this too quickly 20 seconds for
this movement a 5a five wins I can I can
fight but now maybe I can fry it let's
let's quickly check this something like
that yeah there's some there's some
counter play here and this isn't
completely easy but of course is what
black should do it's probably am
probably winning with the cabooze
excellent play but not easy at all yeah
this analysis is great for white I guess
here also e45 is good but I hope I
always kept some some advantage yeah
this is just over yeah I hope you liked
it thanks for watching